educated
[Music]
there we go there you go now you can
breathe now you can breathe
I don't want to cut it towards your hand
either
all right
can you see the cutting any better than
I can
grab grab up some of that
come on buddy sorry
ah
a
thank you
wash your fingers now
yep
all right move move
D
yeah
come on little guy come here
okay
come here
it's okay okay
I got you I got you
[Music]
ouch
strong
I got some of it off
let's see if we drift kid
let's see if we can drift here
closer to you
gotta get closer to you buddy come on
it's okay
it's okay it's okay
all right
it's okay
bless
Ed
foreign
[Music]
it's okay little guy relax
where'd he go
okay
okay
I got you
I got you buddy come on okay
gotcha
[Applause]
down here
oh
hey hey
easy
[Applause]
it was it's female
I'm getting on that corner
thank you
well we just want to get here take these
guys with you
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
come on
[Applause]
whatever
over here come on
dog in the car
oh my God where's it at
least put me in the back right here
right here yeah
Hank is it unlocked
he's right here come on
come on come on buddy
come on come on
foreign
go over there
[Music]